if you're a kevin smith fan you may
already be familiar with jay and silent
bob's cameo in scream 3 but you might
not know the backstory behind it jay and
silent bob are a pair of characters that
first appeared in kevin smith's 1994
movie clerks which is prominently
displayed at the video store in the
original screen jay and bob would become
recurring characters who show up in many
kevin smith films that are part of his
viewers universe and as a thank you for
the free advertising and scream kevin
smith and scream director wes craven
decided to exchange cameos in each
other's movies so jay and silent bob
show up in scream 3 and the following
year wes shows up in jay and silent bob
strike back where he plays wes craven
the director of scream 4 a decade before
he would actually create scream 4. in
addition to that cottonwear's apartment
in the opening of scrim 3 contains a
copy of chasing amy which is also part
of the viewers universe the scene with
jay and silent bob also contains a
couple other cameos which are pretty
much only findable thanks to the
retrospective documentary still
screaming which points out a cameo from
wes craven as the man with the video
camera and scream 3's casting director
lisa beach as the tour guide to learn
how scream 3 may have had a second
killer who died before being revealed
stick around to the end of this video
[Music]
in scream movies don't create psychos
movies make psychos more creative in
scream 2 movies are a scapegoat for
someone who is planning to be a killer
scream 3 reverses this and has the
killer make the movie creating his own
lore every step of the way welcome to
things you missed wanting to capitalize
on the hype train created by scream 1
and 2 producers decided to go ahead
without screenwriter kevin williamson by
replacing him with aaron kruger really
the creator of a nightmare on elm street
is working with a guy named krueger
stage name you should talk judy
jurgenstern
sydney prescott has become a crisis
hotline counselor and she also takes on
a stage name of sorts going by laura to
her callers she's unknowingly following
in the footsteps of her mother who used
the name marina reynolds while working
in hollywood there's a running theme of
pseudonyms in scream 3. most of our main
characters are the actors who are just
as likely to respond to their character
names as their actual names to the point
that it becomes kind of a joke
not sydney sydney
like i'm gail and she's gay obviously
it's more than just a joke though it's
important to the plot because roman's
changing of his last name to bridger is
what helps disguise his true identity as
sydney's brother and the killer let's
get into the things you missed
as with screams 1 and 2 the opening
shows the slaying of the couple only
this time we recognize one of the
victims it's cotton weary and his
girlfriend cotton is complaining that
he's only given a small cameo in stab 3
which is basically his experience in
scream through despite being a big part
of the second movie they kill him off
right away in this one one of the
criticisms of turning scream into a
franchise was that it would become the
very thing that the original scream was
satirizing and we see this intentionally
or not intentionally in scream three's
opening in the last film stab one
attempted to recreate the opening of
scream the death of casey bakker but
certain things are embellished for
hollywood like how they add a shower
scene which seems to have no purpose
other than showing a little skin so
scream three's opening literally does
that in the form of cotton's girlfriend
getting out of the shower there's even a
shot of christine's towel dropping by
her feet very similar to casey's
bathrobe and stab the whole shower
thing's been done vertigo hello it's not
vertigo it's psycho as we've discussed
many times on the show then christine
even channels her inner casey becker
herself when she kicks ghostface to get
away stream 2's opening was all about
the stab movie premiere so there's a
slight nod to that as well when cotton
is frantically driving home he nearly
hits a bus with a stab to advertisement
on the back this next one might not be a
reference this might just be cotton
being entirely focused on saving his
girlfriend but he leaves his car door
open as he goes inside much like bob
sims in halloween who is probably also
focused on one thing entirely as you
know if you've seen scream halloween is
basically considered the big one and
it's referenced all the time but not
that much in scream three although there
is one part where sydney hears her
mother's voice telling her that she'll
protect her from the boogeyman the
boogeyman is a pseudonym for michael
myers in the halloween films ghostface
tries to pressure cotton into revealing
the location of sydney prescott before
offing him and then we see sydney living
a secluded life with her dog by her door
there's a fall of troy poster
advertising the play she was in in
college agamemnon does that mean she
actually went through with being in the
play after defeating mickey and debbie
on its stage that's dedication she also
continues to wear the greek letters
given to her by her boyfriend when the
murders were happening in the last movie
can you really blame her he was the best
guy she ever dated the next character we
meet is gail weathers who's giving a
speech about being a journalist lady a
woman in the crowd is wearing a number
81 jersey not many people know this but
scream 1996 was not the first or last
slasher movie to be called screen the
original was a 1981 film i have not seen
it but according to the letterboxed
rating it is not very good this scene
also has the best extra this lady is
just really into gill's speech this
speech is part of a lecture series
called fw bester lecture series faces of
journalism named after the movie's art
department coordinator claudia bestor
just like the last two movies sydney is
at home when she sees bad news on the tv
that involves her and her past as we're
first introduced to sunrise studio where
most of the movie takes place we hear
the song red right hand by nick cave in
the bad seeds which by this point is
more or less the scream theme song this
is our fourth time hearing it and the
end credits would be the fifth although
that one is a special stream three
version meant to close out the trilogy
stab three's subtitle is returned to
woodsboro and this phrase keeps finding
new meaning throughout the movie it's
actually a leftover from kevin
williamson's original outline for the
script that he planned after writing
scream 2. but most of it was not used
for what would become scream 3. we would
symbolically return to woodsboro
immediately because they're shooting on
the woodsboro sets sydney would return
to woodsboro when she's later chased
through this set later still the focus
of the story is brought back to
woodsborough and we learned new
information about the motivations of
billy and stu and the movie would end
with everybody returning to woodsboro or
at least what appears to be woodsboro to
join sydney at her secluded home but the
first scene on the woodsboro set
contains more depth than what meets the
eye
[Music]
when we meet roman the director of stab
3 he's busy making a case for keeping
the production going after cotton's
death they hire more security hire the
national guard just don't kill the movie
which is funny because he literally
would kill the movie at least for the
time being by killing everyone in it
he's seen arguing with the studio
executive played by roger corman who
tells him that violence in cinema is
kind of a no-no right now which is also
a little joke because roger corman is a
well-known horror producer and director
he literally made movies such as night
of the blood beast a bucket of blood
bloody mama battle of blood island
bloodbath a remake of a bucket of blood
but his concern over gory movies in 1999
was very relevant because stab 3 is the
in-universe stand-in for scream 3 and
scream 3 was going through the same
problems at this time thanks to the
columbine massacre the worst high school
shooting of the millennium the columbine
massacre was carried out by two high
school seniors and that's really the
only similarity to scream that exists
but that didn't stop people who were
already against horror movies everybody
that didn't like horror films that was
in a position of power came after the
studios columbine happened in april 1999
stream 3 started shooting in july so
there was a lot of pressure from the
studio to limit the gore which is why we
see less of it in this movie according
to matthew lillard he was already paid
to appear in scream 3 as the returning
villain stu mocker but columbine put an
end to those plans wes craven attempted
to make sure that the cultural context
was not forgotten by sneaking in this
article about columbine into the scene
where sydney looks through her file at
the police station the other articles in
this file are just nonsense look at this
one the local police chief the first
official commissioned by the city with
the search committed in the name of the
parents the shadowy suspect faces 121
charges of murder kidnapping arms
smuggling fraud and theft his plea is
that he hadn't committed these offenses
said the parent's attorney we will find
the megan at all cost when gail that is
the real gal shows up on set she's hit
by a wave of dreadful familiarity
her misuse of the term deja vu right
outside of sydney's house calls back to
sydney's own misuse of the phrase in
scream one the nostalgia does not end
there though because the new gale aka
jennifer is dressed more like the old
guy but what happens next is not all old
and familiar gael runs into dewey who
has become an advisor for the movie when
the two met in scream 2 dewey was upset
with how gayle portrayed him in her book
now dewey has turned the tables on her
and gayle is upset about how he is
portraying her in stab 3. in my previous
scream analysis videos i pointed out wes
craven's easter eggs to his other major
horror franchise a nightmare on elm
street we don't really get much of that
in the third one but there is a tiny
nightmare scene involving sydney where
she sees her dead mother comes to the
window for being honest though the
reference points a lot more to salem's
lot than it does towards freddy krueger
the next day sarah darling who plays the
character candy in stab has a meeting
with roman at the production office i'm
candy the chick who gets killed second
i'm only in two scenes like cotton's
gripes about his character the complaint
about her screen time could also apply
to her role in scream three she's only
in two scenes there's also another one
to one parallel later where the police
mentioned that there are three versions
of the stab 3 script in order to try to
keep the ending off the internet the
exact same approach was used for scream
3 and then there's the romance between
dewey and gail this time rather than art
imitating life life would imitate art
these two got married for realsies right
before they started shooting anyway
during the line reading roman goes off
script and then claims there's a new
version it's not just a new script it's
a new movie what movie
my movie although we don't know it yet
she's speaking to the real roman and
he's telling the truth by killing the
people involved in stab 3 he's creating
the lore for stab 3. he's creating his
movie candy is the successor to tatum in
scream and her death closely resembles
tatum's ghostface chases are into the
prop room where among all of the movie
props is a fridge remember tatum went to
the garage to get drinks from the fridge
she's punched through a door where she's
left hanging on her stomach and this is
where ghostface gets her she dies in the
exact same position that tatum died in
in the pet flat while gail and dewey are
out to lunch to discuss their past
relationship gail emphasizes the
importance of leaving him alone to go
onto the sequel to 60 minutes claiming
that she could have been the next diane
sawyer it's a bit of a scream to
reference diane sawyer was the
journalist that cotton most wanted to be
interviewed by to gain fame back on the
movie set we have maybe our most obvious
set of crew reference easter eggs yet on
the director's chairs yes they are
called that this one's for peter deming
the director of photography this one
belongs to sheila waldron the script
supervisor and there's one for bruce
allen miller the production designer
that evening the cast gathers for a
depressing wrap party at jennifer's
house where the killing continues with
her security guard and roman continues
to quote unquote write his movie by
literally sending in script pages
telling them what to do via facts uh if
you don't know what facts is look it up
the house blows up taking out tom aka
the new dewey and the old gael punches
the new gale in the face this is yet
another twist on the scream tradition of
miss weathers getting a face full of
knuckles in each film the characters end
up at the police station where they're
finally reunited with sydney one nice
detail at the station is the display of
movie posters and books about film it's
like randy suggested in scream one that
the cops should study movies to save
time speaking of randy he makes his
return in the form of a postmortem video
message which he would use to
communicate a few new horror movie rules
true trilogies are all about going back
to the beginning and discovering
something that wasn't true from the
get-go godfather jedi all revealed
something that we thought was true that
wasn't true this was not his first time
referencing the original star wars
trilogy we saw him mention it in scream
2 and it wouldn't be long before it came
up again the two gales meet the sunrise
studios archivist who is played by
carrie fisher aka princess leia in star
wars
i was up for princess leia
i was this close so who gets it
the one who sleeps with george lucas she
also shares something in common with
sydney her trilogy also involves the
surprise twist where she discovers that
someone is her brother they pull out the
file for maureen prescott who at the
time was going by rina reynolds at the
bottom of her resume we can see that she
started her acting career in theater
just as her daughter would go on to do
one of the plays that she was in was
even called i want to screen so they've
got this whole little family involved in
the dramatic arts maureen with her
acting in plays and horror films roman
the director and sydney the live
performer if candy's death was a
callback to tatum this scene where
sydney has chased through the movie set
is a repeat of her own scene and screen
right down to her screwing herself by
locking herself in with ghostface at the
front door there's also another
similarity in scream she calls the
police using this program on her
computer and zooey immediately shows up
at her door in scream 3 she literally
just yells out for dewey and he comes
running because he's already at the
studio the cops show up and we see this
one new cop named jay west this is the
last crew reference easter egg it's a
reference to the assistant production
coordinator john burton west after
discovering maureen worked in the movies
dewey and the gales confronts the
producer john milton who basically tells
them that he held these parties back in
the day where industry bigwigs took
advantage of actresses and he basically
turned a blind eye to this illegal
activity if you followed the
entertainment industry recently this
might sound familiar in 2018 film
producer harvey weinstein was arrested
as many allegations came out against him
some of which dated back to the 1970s
the very same time period that john
milton claimed to have these parties
could this be a coincidence maybe not
for my understanding weinstein got away
with this for as long as he did because
he targeted small time actresses they
did not take legal action because they
were afraid they'd be blacklisted from
the industry since harvey had many
contacts with all of hollywood for
example two actresses up for parts in
the lord of the rings lost their role
simply because weinstein told peter
jackson that they were a nightmare to
work with that's the kind of influence
that he had but with the advent of the
internet and social media the victims
were able to discover that they were not
the only ones there were a lot like a
whole lot so they came together knowing
that they couldn't all be blacklisted
the point of all this is is that while
they didn't get him arrested for many
years there were rumors about
weinstein's behavior so it's very
possible that wes craven may have known
about these rumors and pulled the
biggest power move of all time by
putting a harvey weinstein character in
his movie which by the way was produced
by bob and harvey weinstein but unlike
these relatively unknown actresses wes
craven had already made it in hollywood
weinstein couldn't really do anything to
him and besides he was already nearing
the end of his career and despite being
the executive producer harvey weinstein
couldn't really stop west from using
scream 3 to make this indirect
accusation because if he ordered west to
change the john milton scene he's just
gonna look guilty according to the
film's editor patrick lucier in an
article on slates the only notes to come
from the weinstein brothers at all came
from harvey's brother bob and he just
had a note about the ending which i'll
get back to later in this video so wes
had his boss backed into a corner where
he could not give any notes it's got to
be one of the most legendary moves that
wes has ever made if in fact this is not
a total huge coincidence hollywood is
full of criminals whose careers are
flourishing i'm not a criminal yeah i
don't think it is and to further add to
the suspicion some of the accusers are
connected to the scream franchise
rosanna arquette is the real life sister
of david arquette's dewey and rose
mcgowan who plays tatum in scream is the
on-screen sister of david arquette
angelina jolie potentially has two
characters named after her in scream
three jennifer jolie and angelina tyler
who says this i did not
get that pink milton to get a leading
role just to die here with second-rate
celebrities like you two the movie's
climax takes place at a mansion party
where roman's birthday is to be
celebrated while we don't realize it at
the time i don't think it's any
coincidence that roman puts his plan
into action on his birthday the day that
he became maureen prescott's bastard
child the party splits up to explore the
mansion and jennifer finds herself stuck
in a passage with the ghost face she
sees dewey on the other side of the
soundproof glass barrier and struggles
to get his attention this is the same
situation that the real girl was in in
scream 2 when she was unable to
communicate with him in the recording
studio there's another repeat of a
scream 2 situation in the basement when
roman is knocked out after falling down
the stairs but his body blocks the only
exit this is like when sydney had to
climb over mickey to escape the crashed
car roman uses his capture of gel and
dewey to lure sydney back into the house
but she's prepared and greets him with
her hidden gun unfortunately for her
this is the one time that she didn't
deliver a follow-up shot to the head and
it comes back to bite her the final
confrontation takes place in the secret
screening room where roman was
theoretically conceived after revealing
himself as the killer there are a couple
more parallels to scream one the
bringing out of a gagged victim and
roman cocking his head just like ghost
face when he first pinned down sydney at
her dad's house after he is defeated
we're treated to an epilogue we see a
sydney essentially let her guard down
for the first time since that fateful
phone call a few years ago then we see
detective kincaid the cop from la who
apparently came back with her he's
holding a bowl of popcorn and says
they're about to start a movie so the
scream trilogy ends just as it began
with popcorn and a movie i personally
think that this was supposed to be the
end of the series by comparing the last
ever scream scene to the first ever we
see the changed state of the world
before and after the defeat of roman the
driving force behind all of the bad
things that happened to sydney in the
1990s however having only one killer
doesn't follow the scream franchise
formula and there could be one more
villain from the production of stab 3
who is yet to be taken care of
[Music]
earlier in this video i mentioned two
darker topics weinstein and columbine i
stated that wes craven and his editor
only received one note on the film and
it came from the innocent of the two
brothers bob weinstein his idea was to
remove the second ghost face to just
focus on roman the reason for this or at
least one of the reasons may have been
teased in the film remember the scene
where the producers are having the
discussion with roman about the future
of the film emphasizing that stringed
instruments in cinema are a big deal
right now a big reason for that was
columbine so the shooting may have also
been part of the reason that they moved
away from the initial concept of having
two killers the accomplice was going to
be angelina tyler the woman who was set
to play the fictional version of sydney
in stab 3. you can still see remnants of
the storyline in the film in fact some
fans believe that angelina is still
canonically the sixth ghost face and she
was killed before she ever got the
chance to reveal herself her story is
that she won the role in a talent search
but we later found out that she did this
by sleeping with the producer you gotta
be praying this movie keeps going of
course i am but not at the expense of
people's lives you either die a hero or
live there are three main sequences that
make angelina look guilty the first is
shortly after jennifer's house explodes
she briefly disappears and comes down
the hill well after everyone else almost
like she knew where to jump to avoid
taking fall damage this allows her to
completely miss the altercation with
roman do we ask her about her
whereabouts but she never actually
answers the question oh thomas in the
house then there's the bathroom scene
which by the way is set up exactly like
the school bathroom scene in scream one
sydney discovers her seemingly changing
into the ghostface costume but angelina
plays it off as her wanting to take
props as souvenirs now that the movie is
shut down but what if this is actually
her getting caught and being the actress
that she is talking her way out of it
this could also be the reason that roman
decides to kill her off he probably
figured that sydney knew she was guilty
and it was better to get rid of her
before she had the chance to be arrested
and interrogated where she would
possibly give them both away he knew
sydney wouldn't accuse her immediately
though because she wouldn't want a
repeat of cotton weary on her conscience
who went to jail because he was
wrongfully accused by sid when she
wasn't quite 100 sure so i think
angelina makes up an excuse quickly
scurries away and goes into the sound
stage to finish putting on the ghostface
costume when sydney goes into the movie
set version of her room there are
clearly two killers here someone is
pushing on the door and then three
seconds later ghost faces all the way on
the other side of the room and behind
her in the window i think the one in the
window is angelina because the shoes we
see during the struggle are the exact
same ones that sydney noticed under the
bathroom stall when the lights go on we
get a better look at angelina wearing
these shoes with a black
skirt
i don't know the terminology for this
piece of clothing but the loose black
fabric could easily help her blend into
the ghostface cloak and the third
sequence where she looks guilty is
roman's birthday party sure they appear
to be using the buddy system for safety
but roman and angelina are each one on
one with a victim dewey and gail also
poke around and find a ghostface mask
cellphone and voice changer in a closet
but these are not romans because he
clearly has his own i can understand
having a backup costume but why have a
second voice changer angelina was
supposed to be with tyson but she
disappears and roman faces death just
like billy did in hindsight he's
probably the one that taught billy how
to make that hollywood level corn syrup
mixture during the big reveal roman even
suggested he gave billy pointers on
being a killer such as having a partner
to sell out once you got caught this
means that roman probably also had a
disposable partner when we last see
angelina she's frantically trying to
leave the house could it be that at this
point she knows that roman is done with
her and she's now just fearing for her
life or is this part of the act we don't
actually see her die she just gets
stabbed in the shoulder and dragged out
of view it's awfully inconclusive for a
scream character to go out like this
maybe scream 5 will feature stew and
angelina as ghostface killers personally
i don't think there's a ton of evidence
to suggest that she's alive though it's
definitely a small possibility but i am
of the belief that she was roman's
accomplice and there's a ton of evidence
to support that let me know your
thoughts on angelina in the comments
scream 3 was marketed as the last screen
the final act the very end so join me
next time on things you missed as i
cover screeform also known as scream4
make sure you subscribe to cz's world
for new horrors every week ring the
death bell and select all notifications
and i will see you in wes craven's final
movie assuming we both survive
[Music]
you